-Welcome back.
Thank you so much
for coming back to the show.
I have so many things
I want to ask you about.
First is Phoenix, the baby.
How old is he?
-He just turned nine months
old yesterday.
-Nine months old.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Get ready to see
the cutest baby.
Look at this baby.
[ Audience awwing ]
-Yeah, that's his Halloween --
one of his Halloween costumes.
-Oh, my gosh, he's so cute.
-It's his first time
in New York.
-Ooh!
How's he taken to traveling?
-He is an amazing traveler,
but this is his first time
experiencing jet lag.
So he's been up till,
like, midnight, 1 a.m.
Yeah.
-Wow.
He's ready to party.
-Yeah.
-Is this true?
His first word was mama?
-No, it was "yas."
[ Laughter ]
-It was not.
There is no way. He said "yas"?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Yas.
-Yas.
-Wonder where he got that from.
-I wonder where he got that
from, yeah.
Last time I think
you said "Stars Are Blind"
was the baby's favorite song.
-Mm-hmm.
-Your song. Is that still true?
-Yes.
He has amazing taste in music.
[ Laughter ]
-Speaking of music,
by the way,
you have a new one coming out.
-Yeah, I'm recording
the new album right now.
-Now, what is it --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Talk to me about, "Lighter."
This is coming out, "Lighter."
-"Lighter" comes out this week.
It's my new song
with Steve Aoki.
-Steve Aoki is my fave.
-Mm-hmm. He's so dope.
We've been friends for 20 years.
I love him so much.
-Any other collabs that
we can look forward to?
-I'm doing my new album
and Sia
is executive producing it.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Wait. The Sia?
-The Sia.
-Wow, this is unbelievable.
-Thank you.
-When is that going to come out?
-That'll be out next year.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love all the things you do.
I always find them so,
so interesting.
This is this is a picture of you
at the Grammys, by the way,
and you're holding
a bedazzled martini.
But it turned out that is not.
That was actually a handbag.
Is that correct?
-Yes.
Peter Dundas designed it.
And it's a Grey Goose
Swarovski crystal bag. Yeah.
-And so what's the partnership
with Grey Goose?
-I am their new
creative director, so...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So what does that mean?
What does that mean exactly?
And how did I pass up this job?
I don't understand.
-Well, since I'm the queen
of sliving, it's...
[ Laughter ]
It's really about
just teaching people
how to slive their best lives
while drinking Grey Goose
martinis.
-Yaaaas.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Do you
make a good martini?
-I do now because it just
comes in the bottle.
All you do is pour it, stir it.
[ Laughter ]
Drink it.
-I guess that's one way
to do it.
Yeah. Why not? Yeah. Can we talk
about "Paris in Love"?
This is coming back
for a second season.
Yes.
-Apparently this is true.
The scene is in this episode.
I don't know if we're going
to show it tonight,
but it's in this season
of your mom, Kathy,
finding out for the first time
that she's a grandma.
You introduce her to the baby?
-Yes. Nobody knew about Phoenix
besides Carter and I.
-Like no one?
-No one.
-You didn't tell your mom?
-I didn't tell anyone.
-Now, this is a problem.
-None of my friends
or my family. No one knew.
-Why not?
Why not Mom?
-[ Laughs ]
Because it was a surprise.
I feel like if she would have
came on here, said something.
-She would have, right?
-It's hard to keep in.
I think it's something
that's so exciting
when your daughter
is going to have a baby,
it's really hard to keep in.
-Yes, honestly,
knowing your mom,
she would have
spilled the beans.
-Yes.
-I would have --
She would have just said,
"by the way" and just said it.
-She's just not a good liar.
Someone would have asked her.
-If she doesn't know,
then she can't tell anyone.
Yeah.
So how did you do it?
-Well, I came in and I
had Phoenix under a blanket,
and I said,
"Two surprises for you."
And then first, I gave her
a baby blue Chanel bag.
Because, you know, who could
be mad after getting Chanel?
[ Laughter ]
And then I said, "And here's
the second surprise,"
and the blanket came down,
and you'll have to watch
the show and see what happens.
-Were there tears?
-There is. Yes.
It was emotional. It was...
It was such a special moment
too, though.
-It really was.
Yeah.
Please give my best to your mom
and your dad, by the way.
They've always been great to me.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Paris Hilton in season
two of "Paris in Love."
Take a look at this.
-It's amazing.
We're gonna be parents.
-I'm so excited.
His name is going to be Phoenix.
I've always wanted to name
my children after cities
or states or countries.
So when I told Carter
the name, he loved it.
I just don't even know
what to expect.
Like, I know expect a baby,
but I have never had
my own baby, so I don't know.
♪♪
Oh, my goodness.
I'm gonna be a mom.
-Get ready. No spoilers.
It's so good.
Paris Hilton, everybody.
Season two of
"Paris in Love" premieres
November 30th on Peacock.
We'll be right back
with stand-up from Jared Freid.
Stick around, everybody.